moscou antoine claireaux fin antoine
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors que retenir un encore de cette
sortie de vladimir poutine au forum de
davos la première depuis 2009
oui tout à fait bien son son
intervention a largement été consacrés à
cette pandémie à cette pandémie à ses
causes et surtout aux réponses qu'on
peut y apporter il a rappelé que cette
pandémie a renforcé les déséquilibres au
niveau mondial et en particulier sur le
plan social et d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs le premier défi qu'il aquila
qui les rides identifier le défis
socio-économiques en effet des progrès
ou pourtant été constatée ces dernières
années au niveau macroéconomique en
partie il a donné l'exemple de la chine
avec une forte partie de la population
chinoise qui a pu sortir qui a pu
s'extraire de ce seuil de pauvreté de la
pauvreté et mais voilà ces dernières
années ces derniers surtout ces derniers
mois avec cette pandémie de coronavirus
plusieurs pays même des pays occidentaux
ont revu leur part de la population sous
le seuil de pauvreté augmente et donc
c'est une des raisons une une des raison
de ses déséquilibres qui peut provoquer
une intolérance un mécontentement social
je cite vladimir poutine il y a
également parlé d'un autre défi celui de
l' équilibre entre vie personnelle et
accumulation des données par des grands
groupes privés en effet certains géants
du numérique sur certains aspects
commencent à concurrencer certains
certains états et vladimir poutine s'est
inquiétée de ce fait en prenant
l'exemple
de ce qui se passe en ce moment aux
états unis troisième défi selon vladimir
poutine les problèmes actuels que l'on
peut identifier sur la scène
internationale en effet il a constaté
les sanctions économiques qui sont
imposés à de nombreux pays aidé mais
aussi des restrictions sur la
possibilité de pouvoir s'informer
librement pour lui il faut restaurer la
confiance à l'international avec un
véritable retour à la multi pauline à la
multipolarité il a rappelé d'ailleurs le
rôle de la russie dans dans le monde ya
dans la résolution des conflits récents
et là il a cité l'exemple du conflit
dans le haut karabakh entre l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan ou encore le rôle de la
russie
conjointement avec la turquie et l'iran
dans la situation en syrie
il a également évoqué le désarmement et
avec ce désarmement
le texte qui est va être prolongé avec
les états unis je vous propose d'écouter
ce morceau de vladimir poutine
il y a le problème de la sécurité
internationale et ce choix vous venez de
parler de l'entretien que j'ai eu hier
avec le président biden sur la
prorogation des traités et des accords
qui avaient décidé mais malgré cela il
ya quand même un certain nombre de
contradictions qui demeurent dans le
monde
le manque de volonté de résoudre ce
problème peut être un défi important ici
dans notre siècle et lien j'espère bien
sûr qu'il n'y aura pas de grand conflit
mondial qui vont déclencher la fin de la
civilisation
mais malgré tout la situation peut
évoluer de façon imprévisible a entendu
nous allons prendre le magnifique action
de mesures pour éviter que cela se
produise mais enfin il faut être
confiante que il faut être conscient que
tout cela peut se produire à avoir une
influence sur l'évolution de notre monde
malgré les défis manière poutine a
appelé la communauté internationale à
rester optimiste et chercher des
approches communes afin de répondre aux
défis
de cette pandémie aux défis actuels pour
lui la stabilité et le développement des
pays doit prendre en compte le facteur
social donc sans laisser de côté les
laissés pour compte de cette crise il a
d'ailleurs identifié quatre priorités à
savoir l'accès à un logement un travail
aux soins mais aussi à une formation à
une éducation avant voilà quatre
priorités que tout un chacun tous pays
devrait pouvoir fournir à sa population
pour terminer il a appelé à davantage de
corps de se coordonner davantage entre
les pays et ce dans de très nombreux
domaines et en particulier pour
commencer avec cette lutte contre la
pandémie de coronavirus merci beaucoup à
vous antoine claireaux pour toutes ces
précisions en direct depuis moscou